Senate Republicans have a new tax reform
plan it's due to be released today and
it's different from the House version
House Republicans want for tax brackets
but according to the new york times the
senate bill would create more than that
it would also eliminate deductions for
state and local taxes the House bill
would let homeowners deduct property tax
up to ten thousand dollars
senators also want to limit the number
of people who pay estate tax instead of
getting rid of it South Dakota Senator
John Thune is chairman the Senate
Republican Conference that makes him the
third ranking Republican in the Senate
he's with us from Capitol Hill senator
good morning good morning Charlie help
us understand how the Senate bill is
shaping up to be different in the House
bill for example those that we just
listed in terms of state and local
deductions simply doing away with them
also there's some reports in the
Washington Post that you might delay
until 2019 the the corporate tax
reduction can you help us understand
that will all be rolled out later today
Charlie but the details are in some
cases slightly different than what the
house did we took a slightly different
approach on some of the major issues but
the contours of the bill will largely
follow the houses action in it if you
can use an analogy I mean we're all on
the same team we want to get to the same
end zone and sometimes we call it
different slightly different plays in
the house in the Senate but that's the
way the process works so you'll you'll
see all those details when they come out
later today but we think we've got a
strong bill that advances economic
growth and higher wages and better jobs
will it have a 1.7 billion dollar
deficit it will have really I'm sorry
1.7 trillion no that's I know the
dimensions here but it'll have and it'll
be consistent with the instruction that
we were given by the Budget Committee
which was a 1.5 trillion dollar deficit
to be dealt with in the form of so
hopefully higher economic growth well
the tax brackets change in your planning
your planning to keep the seven brackets
that we have now we keep hearing
different things well there will be some
differences Gail in the in the brackets
from what we have today
and probably as well from what the house
did but what we wanted to do is to
design a tax code that delivered
meaningful tax relief to middle-income
families and then of course on the
business side a tax code that lowers
that rate down so our businesses can be
competitive in the global marketplace
which all the analysis shows leads to
higher wages for American workers so
those are two key objectives in this
bill we think we accomplished them and
on the individual side by doubling the
standard deduction lowering rates and
expanding the child tax credit you
really do Drive tax relief to a
middle-income families which is
something they desperately need can you
guarantee that no middle-class family
will see their taxes go up nor I don't
think you can guarantee every filer is
that that's going to be the case but as
we look at this we're trying to maintain
the tax burden similar to what it is
today that the distribution of this
flows through all the different brackets
in a way that's consistent with what
Americans are seeing today in terms of
their tax burden so we're trying to keep
progressivity in the code and in all the
different income cohorts make sure that
people are getting meaningful tax relief
and I think that the bill will
accomplish that but can you guarantee
that every single filer might you know
have some different experience I don't
think you can guarantee that a question
on as you know there's gonna be some
opposition from some of your friends in
the Northeast region about the
elimination of deductions for state and
local taxes can you that can you explain
the Republican philosophy about why that
should be eliminated well it's a you
know we're trying to do away with a lot
of itemized deductions in the code and
we you know by doubling the standard
deduction it will they're about less
than a third of the people in the
country who itemize today after this we
think it'll be less than 10% who
actually itemized so it's designed to
bring simplification to the code in
terms of that deduction it's been around
for a while but it also is one that we
think subsidizes the states that have
higher taxes and eliminating that
deduction I think will force States to
take a look at their budgets and we
think it's something that is a
an anachronism and the code that needs
to go away now you can count boats in
this than you think this would be a
straight party-line boat and can it be
passed before January 1st I think it
could be passed before January 1st
Charlie as to where the votes will come
down I think it right now it's going to
depend largely on when the bill comes
out and we take it to the Finance
Committee next week which we will will
have a full markup there we'll spend all
week on it next week and then we get to
the floor it will be open to amendment
I'm hoping in the end there will be
Democrats who will vote for it I think
they're going to be enough features
about this bill that will be attractive
to them that we may attract some
Democrats but you know right now we we
won't know and I think I guess I'm
hopeful that that'll be the case and and
we're gonna work hard to make this an
attractive bill that both sides will
want to support are there plans to take
Democrats out to lunch
her Gail it doesn't hurt a lot of us
start of a start our day and the Senate
gym together so we have lots of good
conversations down there working about
the issues always good to see you
senator Stan thank you so much for
taking the time nice to be with you we
think so too to see you here